قال مصدر عسكري يمني للجزيره ان قوات
انصار الله الحوثيين استهدفت سفينه في
البحر الاحمر من جانبها قالت هيئه عمليات
التجاره البحريه البريطانيه انها تلقت
تقريرا عن وقوع حادث على بعد 50 ميلا
بحريا غرب مدينه الحديده اليمنيه ولم يبلغ
عن وقوع اضرار او
اصابات من جهتها قالت القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه ان جماعه انصار الله الحوث شنت
مساء الثلاثاء هجوما معقدا من اليمن
بالمسيرات والصواريخ المضاده للسفن واضافت
القياده ان الهجوم تم بمسيرات ايرانيه
وصواريخ كروز وصواريخ مضاده للسفن ولم
يسفر عن اصابات او اضرار وقالت ان
الحوثيين شنوا هجومهم على جنوب البحر
الاحمر صوب خطوط الشحن البحريه الدوليه
واوضحت ان طائرات وسفنا امريكيه وسفينه
بريطانيه اسقطت 18 مسيره وصاروخي كروز
وصاروخ بالستي مضاد
للسفن من امام ميناء جيبوتي مراسل الجزيره
حسن رزاق حسن اذا البحر الاحمر لا يهدا
بتطورات اخرها اذا ما اعلنت عنه القياده
الوسطه الامريكيه ووصفته
بالهجوم المعقد الذي انطلق من اليمن ما
المعطيات المتوفره
بخصوصه بالفعل وسيله المعطيات هنا في
البحر الاحمر متسارعه ومتغيره بحسب الكثير
من المصادر الملاحيه اشاروا ان هناك نقص
في امدادات القطع قطع الحربيه والسفن من
قبل الدول المشاركه فيما يسمى بعمليه حار
الازدهار وهذا ما زاد العب على البحريه
الامريكيه هنا في في هذه المناطق هناك
مدمرتين صواريخ تعمل على مدار الساعه وهي
يو اس اس ام ماسون يو اس كارلي وتعمل على
مدار الساعه لتامين هذه المناطق لكن حتى
هذه اللحظه لم تتمكن هذا مؤشر على ان
الهجمات اصبحت تطال حتى منطقه جنوب البحر
الاحمر هناك الشطر الغربي المحاذي لموانئ
الجيبوتيه والارت وهناك الشطر الشرقي من
مضيق باب المندب المحاذي للموانئ اليمنيه
بعض السفن باتت تختار العبور من هذه
المناطق لكن ايضا يتم استهدافها من قبل
الحوثي طبعا هذه المؤشرات كانت بحسب ما
اعلنت السلطات الجبو سابقا ان الولايات
المتحده كانت تريد ان تثبت منصه صواريخ من
هذه المناطق لاستهداف الحوثي لكن على لسان
وزير رئيس الوزراء الجبوسي رفض جبوتي هذا
الامر رفضا قاطعا وقالت لا يمكن استهداف
اي مناطق اخرى من قبل اراضين وبالتالي ليس
هناك حل امام البحريه الامريكيه سوى
الدوريات المكثفه ل مدمرات الصواريخ في
هذه المناطق نشهد بشكل متكرر وسوء هذه
المدمرات للتزود بالوقود واجراء الصيانه
الاعتياديه هذا يعني ان هناك كثافه في
العمل وكثافه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتمكن
من تامين هذه المناطق على اي حال المعطيات
هنا ما زالت تتسارع الجبو ايضا اكدت ان
الحل يكمن في ايقاف الحرب في غزه وايقاف
فلسطين لكن كافه
هذه الدوريات لن تكون فعاله باعتبار ان
المناطق شاسعه وايضا السفن سواء السفن
الفرنسيه التي تشارك ايضا اشارت انها سوف
سوف تؤمن فقط مصالحها الوطنيه لكن ليست
معنيه بالسفن الاخرى وبالتالي هذا الامر
ان
لم لم يتم ايقاف الحرب في غزه يبدو ان
جماعه الحوثي مستمره في استهداف السفن
التي تريد ان تتوجه الى الموان
الاسرائيليه حسن رزاق مراسلنا من امام
ميناء جبوتي شكرا جزيلا لك